and the rise of some new powers that
aren't totally comfortable with the with
the distribution of arrangements in the
world and and the rules such as they are
so when the Russians start talking about
not having rules or the end of the old
order I think this is their way of
saying we're not comfortable we think
what exists out there is biased against
us it's there to help the United States
and its allies and as the guy said in
the movie we're not going to take it
anymore
and that's what I think we're beginning
to say afterwards airs on book TV every
Saturday at 10:00 p.m. and Sunday at
9:00 p.m. Eastern you can watch all
previous afterwords programs on our
website book TV org
book TV is on Twitter follow us to get
publishing news scheduling updates
author information and to talk directly
with authors during our live programs
twitter.com slash book TV
good evening thanks so much for joining
us tonight
my name is Yael I am the community
relations manager here at the bookstore
and tonight's event is part of a series
of events that we hold here
featuring authors both from NYU and from
other other far places like Boston
Cambridge were really delighted to be
featuring Carolyn light this evening
Carolyn is the author of a new book
stand your ground a history of America's
love affair with lethal self-defense she
will be joined by NYU's professor and
Pamela Sweeney and they will be talking
amongst themselves about what and they
promised to to make it very lively and
then we'll we'll have a Q&A session so
just a quick introduction
yes Caroline light is director of
undergraduate studies in studies of
women gender and sexuality at Harvard
University she's also the author of a
previous book from 2014 that pride of
race and character the roots of Jewish
benevolence in the Jim Crow South which
was published by NYU press and the
levine e is professor of performing
studies and social and cultural analysis
at nyu and she's also the director of
the center for the study of gender and
sexuality here at nyu it's with great
pleasure that i am here to welcome both
of you and welcome people here in the
audience thanks so much for joining us
and let's have a little pause for a very
important very important topic that I
think is very timely to all of us thanks
so much for being here and please
welcome Caroline light and thanks so
much everybody for being here on a
school night to talk about somewhat
demoralizing things and I also I want to
thank NYU bookstore for hosting me it's
a real honor to be here and especially
to thank and Pellegrini for engaging in
this conversation with me and inviting
me into her classroom today where we had
a really interesting discussion with our
students about the legal roots of
contemporary lethal self-defense and has
actually been an intellectual influence
in my work for the past couple of
decades obviously she's a prodigy five
years she was five years old when she
published her book performance anxieties
but a lot of the work that I do on
racialization and structures of legal
and epistemological exclusion are
directly derivative of the work that
she's done so I want to thank her for
that
so um where should we start well you
know the book is
Oh topical I mean and I guess I
I wondered what can history offer right
so this is a book that you began writing
sort of the same after the the death of
Trayvon Martin so in 2012 we here still
far too often about the lethal use of
force against young black and brown men
in particular yeah and so it's this is a
topic that's in the news all the time
but what can history how could history
help us think about which subjects may
be targeted for death with impunity
and who gets to use who gets to
weaponize fear yeah that's it that's an
excellent question and so I am sorry can
you all hear me if I stand okay
I'm obviously trained as a historian so
typically when I try to look for answers
to urgent social issues in the
contemporary universe I tend to look
into the past to try to understand
what's the genealogy of this way of
thinking in this case the weaponization
of fear as as Professor Pellegrini just
said and and for me I I was very
surprised by what I found when I started
looking back into legal doctrine not
just of the United States but prior to
the instantiation of the United States
English common law doctrines that
endowed particular kinds of social
actors with the privilege of using
lethal self-defense in particular
circumstances so one of the things that
I discovered that I found really
interesting was the roots of the castle
doctrine when you look at stand your
ground laws which are now a reality in
different iterations in 33 states in the
United States so they vary according to
the state but they're often referred to
as castle laws so this invocation of
that old adage a man's house is his
castle
really haunts this sort of justification
of these staying around laws the idea
that you have a right to protect
yourself in your home
from danger without first retreating
however its mayor it's misleading it's a
historical because truthfully the Castle
Doctrine is about your right to protect
yourself in your home and stand your
ground laws and Dow people with the
power to fight back with lethal violence
in public spaces beyond their home and
it is actually selective in the way
stand your ground laws are adjudicated
so as we've seen with as you mentioned
Trayvon Martin but also with others like
Marissa Alexander as well stand your
ground laws do not apply evenly to
everyone they're very selectively
enforced so I would say one of the
lessons of history is to show the
inaccurate way in which stain your
grounds laws get promoted as being a
universal appeal to the safety of
everyone's Castle so if the initial
premise is that within your own home you
and the you might not just be just
anyone you but right the owner of the
home the property holder has a right to
defend himself and his family in his own
home how does it move from being located
in a particular private space to being
something that it's I don't know
portable you get to take some people get
to take it with them right into a public
space such that they can defend
themselves yeah in a shared in a park
for example or a roadway right right it
changes a lot in translation from from
England to the United States so one of
the things I try to show in the book is
how this idea of lethal self-defense and
the Castle Doctrine shift in space and
time so for instance it's in the early
republic in the United States that the
duty to retreat begins to get undermined
in a serious way through certain legal
battles can you say a little bit more
about the duty to retreat what does that
in command someone to do so the duty to
retreat was one of the central legal
doctrines in English common law it was
that
if someone was attacking you you did not
have a right to fight back with lethal
violence until your quote back was up
against the wall
so you were supposed to try to get away
as much as you could before you fight
back the one exception to that was the
castle doctrine that gets instituted in
1604 that in a court case in England
where we get this old adage a man's
house is his castle
so the castle doctrine then provides an
exception for someone who's attacked in
their home but originally there's a duty
to retreat and that duty to retreat also
exists in the United States and I argue
too in the book I show in the book that
the duty to retreat wherever you are
still exists for certain social actors
and they tend to be those social actors
who are most vulnerable politically
economically etc but so how does so if
the notion of a duty to retreat except
in the limited space of the house comes
to the United States or it comes to the
the u.s. called the colonies that become
the United States how does it expand I
mean what's the what are those some
moves because this I mean I think one of
the things that you're doing in the book
and this is where history thinking about
this historically is so helpful you're
kind of showing that the obvious nough
summer say shion's we have now about
self-defense it's not obvious at all
it happens through a set of sort of
legal actions social actions kind of
then it gets knit together so it seems
inevitable right afterwards but at the
time it wasn't it isn't no it really
isn't I mean I could there's a section I
can read that sort of lays the
groundwork for this but I show in the
book that there's a certain set of
cultural economic political
circumstances that come to bear in the
United States on that duty to retreat
and that in the end make the duty to
retreat in commensurate with white
masculinity and with the priorities of
manifest destiny so ultimately this duty
to retreat is completely incompatible
with the for instance the spread of the
nation from one coast to the other it
becomes incompatible with white masks
and honor and I show that through
different kinds of court battles in
particular because the law provides a
particularly salient archive when you're
looking at the ways in which different
laws get a Jew's dit adjudicated for
different kinds of social actors so what
was true for one kind of social actor
would not be true for another you talk
about the case of Thomas Selfridge yeah
right
from the early 19th century and Boston
and could you tell us about that case
because this is such a kind of like the
the her moment this movement this sort
of expansion of the duty to retreat so
so the case of Thomas Selfridge happens
in Boston and it's I think it's within
two years of the infamous killing of
Alexander Hamilton by Aaron Burr so it's
just within a couple of years of that it
is not it doesn't become as famous but
it becomes a landmark legal case that
gets referred to in later 19th century
cases about the duty to retreat so I
could do you want me to read the section
on this okay so this is early in the
book and it starts with this trial
so when Thomas Selfridge stood trial for
manslaughter in December 1806 the young
nation's laws were vague on the topic of
lethal self-defense this 32 year old
lawyer had killed a man
in the streets of Boston claiming that
he did so to protect himself from grave
danger the English common law on which
United States legal foundations were
based held that one must withdraw in the
face of an attack and not retaliate
until retreating as far as he
conveniently or safely can the crown or
the King held the capacity of the DES
ace in her arrium of vindicating or
avenging the wrongs that citizens
inflicted on one another and accordingly
the taking of another's life was among
the most serious of crimes one commonly
perhaps ironically punishable by death
yet in the United States the idea of
backing away from a threat or of
allowing the governor
to protect one from harm clashed with
the ideals of Independence and
individual rights on which the nation
was founded and while the race of the
men at the center of this landmark case
went unmentioned
whiteness and masculinity along with
property ownership were as critical to
the distribution of political rights as
to the right to defend oneself while
legal doctrine upheld the duty to
retreat popular opinion in the young
Republic increasingly saw a white man's
retreat from an assault especially an
assault on his honor as cowardly as
incompatible with the values of liberal
democracy so I talked a little bit about
how Enlightenment thinkers like Thomas
Hobbes and John Locke challenged the
monarchies monopoly on lethal punishment
in 1851 1651 Hobbes was the first to
invoke in an alien Ville right to
self-defense he wrote a covenant not to
defend myself from force by force is
always void and in his second essay on
civil government in 1690 Locke invoked
self-defense as that great law of nature
he argued whosoever sheddeth man's blood
by man shall his blood be shed so I
mentioned before that the exception to
the English duty to retreat was the
castle doctor and that originates in a
case in 1604 and popularizes the notion
of a man's house is his castle
but while there's no reference to the
race of the man authorized to defend his
castle in practice this castle doctrine
originates predominantly in the context
of white property owner owners
predominantly white men in the United
States the legal conditions that exclude
most women and non-whites from access to
political and economic rights and
property ownership guaranteed that the
castle would serve as a safe haven for
white men and their property so I go on
to talk a little bit about the legal
doctrine of coverture and we talked
about this in your classroom coverture
is essential
we're under British common law when a
woman got married she relinquished all
of her property and any of her political
rights to her husband essentially as Sir
William Blackstone writes the very being
or legal existence of the woman is
suspended during marriage or at least
incorporated and consolidated into that
of her husband under whose wing
protection and cover she performs
everything so hence the name Kovich er
the castle that a married woman occupied
belonged entirely to her husband so
there the the central mythology of this
is that the married woman lives under
her husband's protection within his
castle coverture has a lot of social
implications one is that a woman could
not defend herself from an abusive
spouse the law allowed husbands to
discipline their wives through the right
of chastisement or physical punishment
according to Blackstone a husband quote
might give his wife moderate correction
end quote the only exception to the
masculine monopoly on violence existed
when a white woman protected her
chastity so and and this had to be from
a stranger too so there was no such
thing as marital rape this was not and
there was no acknowledgement of marital
rape when a woman said I do to marriage
she essentially consented to sex
whenever her husband wanted it in fact
in this nation marital rape was not
outlawed until the 1990s so this is
another I would say a legal fiction in
the words of Carla Holloway who writes
about the inter the intersection of
literary knowledge with with legal legal
knowledge so there's this right to
protect her chastity by granting men
full authority over their wives and
their daughters the doctrine of
coverture coexisted harmoniously with
settler colonialism and legalized
slavery so I talked about the way in
which the legal doctrine of coverture is
also enter in placated with legalized
slavery and set
colonialism the legal immunities of the
castle doctrine and a woman's defense of
chastity did not extend to Native
Americans and African Americans unless
they were free property owners like
coverture slavery and settler
colonialism rested on the belief in the
supremacy of Christian men of European
descent and their necessary control over
other human beings the law allowed
masters liberal discretion when it came
to disciplining their slaves and most
slave owning states prohibited African
Americans free as well as enslaved from
owning weapons while a few of the laws
punished masters for outright killing
their slaves usually murderous or
abusive slave masters received scant
discipline by the law the number one
incentive preventing a master from
killing his slave was his monetary
investment in the slaves labor living at
the intersection of white supremacy and
patriarchy enslaved women could not
legally defend themselves from most
forms of violence valued for their labor
and reproductive capacity which
contributed to the owners workforce
enslaved women played a vital role in
slavery sexual economy a slave sexual
consent was made irrelevant by her
status as chattel as property rather
than person as legal systems that
undergirded the young nation social
order coverture and slavery existed in
structural independent interdependence
ensuring that the most valuable property
remained under the control of white men
legal doctrines governing the
hierarchical relations of husband and
wife of master and slave were
inextricably connected
thus law and custom conspired to exclude
the nation's most vulnerable from the
legal right to defend themselves so
that's the historical context in which
this case with Thomas Selfridge takes
place Selfridge was a devoted Federalist
and he got in this major feud with a man
named Benjamin Austin who was a
democratic Republican or the the party
of Jefferson he
published a statement in the Boston
Gazette calling Austin a coward a liar
and a scoundrel I won't get into the
details they were fighting over a
catering bill I'm not tweeting it today
he would be 23 I am absolutely so this
was a really productive akut of kind of
gesture and it resulted in Benjamin
Austin threatening to send somebody to
settle the score with Thomas Selfridge
so Selfridge armed himself with a pistol
because he was described at court as
being weak and infirm he said to one
acquaintance that he was not fit for
bullying or fisticuffs but he was
prepared to defend himself that
afternoon on August 4th he was walking
towards the public exchange on State
Street where he encountered Austin's 18
year old son Charles Charles Austin was
a sturdy athletic young man a Harvard
student and at that moment he was
rapidly approaching Selfridge with a
cane in his upraised hand and witnesses
disagree over who made the first assault
but the end result was that Selfridge
fired killing Austin and and Selfridge
was taken into police custody and
arraigned for manslaughter at the end of
the legal battle so this case goes on
for quite a while it receives a lot of
sort of popular interest and especially
because it was political because it was
between these warring parties or members
of these warring parties it did receive
a lot of press also Paul Revere was on
the jury which I find fascinating as
well in in the closing arguments the
defense argued that the castle doctrines
defense of habitation applied to Thomas
Selfridge and that he had a legal right
to protect himself just as people were
allowed to protect their homes he said
every man is bound and ordered to defend
and protect his own life when the
government cannot do it for him which I
find resonates a lot today so further
echoing ha
the defense argued that no law created
by civil society may abridge so
essential and natural a right as that of
self-defense on the prosecution side
they argued that not only was it illegal
to kill and defensive ones honor the
practice was incompatible with liberal
democracy he cautioned the jury against
a society in which the would be noble
shall be allowed with his gold hilted
cane or his elegantly mounted pistol in
defense of his honor to play a secure
but mortal game under such circumstances
violent chaos would reign supreme and
the volumes of laws would become
pavement for the soles of my shoes
although the defense insisted on
Selfridges natural right to defend both
his safety and his honor the judges
instructions to the jury upheld the duty
to retreat the judge suggested that
Selfridge could have escaped Austen's
attack through less lethal means however
his instructions did not resonate with
the jury which swiftly returned a
verdict of not guilty Selfridge went
free so this trial becomes the precedent
for all the later cases in the 19th
century on the duty to retreat is there
a duty to retreat in a public space and
this case says well actually not really
it depends on who you're talking about
so this case provides legal foundation
for the gradual decay throughout the
United States of the duty to retreat
Selfridges case proved that a man
violently attacked in a public place
might not be obligated to retreat before
defending himself in practice however
this was a recite a right reserved only
for particular people in specific
circumstances I mean you've just
sketched out also a genealogy of how a
doctrine that allowed okay some white
men because those white men that owned
property to defend their property
understood as a domicile but also the
property of the wife and the children
and what slaves they might own since
slaves also property so this movement
from the right to defend your property
and again people can be property to that
it's fault moves into public space but
what I found so fascinating in the
Selfridge case is that the defense is
arguing and Selfridge I guess attest to
this as well that somehow were he to
have been bested by this eighteen year
old he would have lost his manliness it
would to lose his manly honour would
actually have made it impossible for him
to live even if he survived the beating
so there's something about the property
value of white masculinity absolutely
that's moved with him so I'm so that the
logic of property is there in public at
least for that subject who's whose
property rights over his self his
identity yeah are considered valuable no
exactly I mean I couldn't put any better
myself I mean even in in the small part
that I read there's an invocation of
this defense of habitation which is
really what the castle doctrine is about
it's about your right to protect your
domicile and there's a stretching that
goes on here this this epistemological
stretching of the defense of habitation
to the defense of white masculine honor
itself and there are so many different
vectors that influence this in the early
republic one of which i i think is the
the command to spread the influence of
european descended christian
civilization from sea to shining sea
there's very much even you know even in
Thomas Jefferson's vision of of
so-called limited government which was
at the heart of that debate between the
Federalists and and the Democratic
Republicans many of us have seen the
musical Hamilton so and I don't think
lien Manuel Miranda has made a musical
yet about the Selfridge case but I'm
gonna see you next one this is the next
this is his next frontier but Jefferson
to even in his sort of doctrine of
limited government was all about
expanding the the territory itself like
through the Louisiana Purchase so this
was something that became very
naturalized once the early republic
takes root so I feel like that's a
part of it too is the expansion of
property and and obviously embedded in
all of this is settler colonialism I
don't spend nearly enough time in this
book unpacking the naturalized
understanding that of course these
european descended people are going to
spread their influence without regard to
people who were already living in the
territory so that's part of it too
the naturalized violence that takes
place against Aboriginal people and you
know the Naturalization to of an ocean
of property that is alienable that you
can actually sell and trade and so then
the license killing of those who have a
different view of property who might not
actually see land as property in the
same way so you can kill those who don't
have a notion of property because that's
a violation of property where it's a
sign of their lack of capacity for
higher civilization their failure to
recognize value and property value value
like you're saying alienation of land as
property so yeah I think that's a part
of it I definitely think there's an
economic principle to this as well but
the sort of long and short of it is once
this case happens it doesn't take long
throughout the 19th century for the duty
to retreat to essentially become gutted
but specifically for white men and
there's a multiple times where there's
appeal to white masculine vulnerability
that kind of mirrors what you were
saying about selfridge the fact that
he's kind of weak that he's not fit for
bullying or fisticuffs later cases
reflect this sense that oh no this man
is vulnerable he's a veteran he's
injured or whatever white masculine
vulnerability becomes central to
reasonable suspicion of threat and
that's a recurrent theme today too
is this sort of reverse victimization
narrative I mean you just effectively
describe you know jury nullification is
happening right so the the jury acquits
it's all forged in some ways against the
instructions of the judge so absolutely
and this is about the question of from
whose perspective is violence or and for
fear reasonable so could you could you
alright
let's fast forward to the future which
is in some sense back to the future
given this history and are there some
contemporary examples about how this
this question of reasonable self-defense
is you know perpetuates race racial and
gender biases right and that's sort of I
think that's what led me to do this work
is that the concept of reasonable haunts
the margins of all these contemporary
cases right now so when we look at what
happened to Trayvon Martin five years
ago his killer was acquitted based on
the jury's understanding of his
reasonable sense of fear and anxiety
when faced by an unarmed black teenager
in a Florida suburb so this notion of
who has reasonable fear for whom is that
fear intelligible right so in the eyes
of that jury it was intelligible it was
understandable that george zimmerman was
fearful when he saw trayvon martin i
have in the end of the book a bunch of
cases i can read a little bit about the
case of Cece McDonald I feel is also a
really good sort of illustration of how
reasonable fear ends up in some ways
selectively creating a duty to retreat
that continues to haunt certain groups
of people
in other words groups of people that are
excluded from that idea of reasonable
anxiety and fear so I don't know if
people are familiar with this case of
Cece Alexander so this was back in 2000
I mean sorry Cece McDonald in June 2011
back then Cece McDonald was 23 years old
she's a black transgender woman and she
was attacked by a group of white people
yelling racist and sexist obscenities a
white woman slashed her face with a
glass bottle creating a wound that would
require stitches
in the fight that ensued 47 year old
Dean Schmitz
a white man with a criminal history
attacked McDonald as she was trying to
flee the scene McDonald stabbed him with
a pair of scissors that she kept in her
purse
Schmitz died later from loss of blood
and McDonald was arrested and charged
with second degree murder so we know how
all of this ends but essentially in in
the course the case or the court case
that resulted McDonald maintained and
many witnesses maintained that she was
acting in self-defense that in fact she
was trying to flee this group of people
that were attacking her the prosecuting
attorney Michael Freeman insisted that
McDonald had had every opportunity to
retreat to safety this happened in
Minnesota which is not a
stand-your-ground state so Freeman cited
the individual duty to retreat from
danger when you're attacked outside the
home right so McDonald's failure to
retreat adequately therefore made her a
murderer insisting quote that the scales
of justice have got a blindfold on them
for a reason end quote
Freeman signaled the blindness of the
law to human differences such as race
and gender and sex thus he could dismiss
the racist and transphobic origins of
the attack against which McDonald had
defended herself insisting that the
deadly encounter was no different from
an ordinary bar brawl with both sides
being equal in the end McDonald pled
guilty to second-degree manslaughter and
she was sentenced to 41 months she
served 19 in an all-male prison
according to Katy Burgess executive
director of the trans youth support
network MacDonald was placed on trial
for surviving a hate crime so I have a
bunch of cases and and I keep seeing new
ones it seems like every time you turn
on the news there's another case of
somebody whether it's a small
child or a person of color a gender
non-conforming person who is attacked
and fights back or a woman who is a
domestic violence survivor who fights
back against her attacker and ends up in
prison in spite of being in a stain your
ground state so one of my conclusions
from the study is that for all the
reasons we were talking about before
with the the specific coding around
reasonableness on which so much of the
adjudication of criminal law is based
stain your ground laws in many ways they
don't just not help socially minoritized
people and protect them and give them
the capacity to protect themselves in
fact I think they exacerbate the already
powerful racial and gender and justices
in our criminal and justice system so in
many ways there's there's plenty of
evidence to suggest that stain Your
Ground laws give certain groups of
people usually socially dominant actors
a license to kill
while excluding the vast majority of us
from the right to defend ourselves but
and and get their caste and the language
of being race neutral and gender neutral
as in the case of Cece McDonald where
yeah the prosecutor effectively says you
know and I mean this is the kind of the
theft of the language of liberal
diversity and we can have you know blob
we can talk about this the law is blind
let's you know in the name and and
here's the violence being done against
this trans woman
and it's actually the law shows just how
neutral it is by prosecuting her as if
her vulnerability wasn't a factor and
what happened to her exactly exactly and
it happens time and time again I mean
there's there's so many different cases
I've there's a case of a young trans man
that's less well known kai Peterson
who's in Georgia right now serving a
sentence in
a woman's prison so to add insult to
injury the trans individual who becomes
criminalized serves time in the prison
of the the gender with which they don't
identify and he was criminalized because
he shot his rapist he had a positive
rape kit he had all kinds of evidence in
his favor
did not have money to appoint a great
attorney the court-appointed attorney
didn't even tell him about Stand Your
Ground laws not that it would have
necessarily exonerated him but we see so
many different layers to this it isn't
just about racial exclusions or
patriarchal exclusions homophobic
exclusions there's a class element
whereby if you lack the resources to to
hire yourself a really good defense
attorney you run the risk of being
criminalized or having to plead down and
this happens a lot to survivors of
intimate partner violence who fight back
against against their violent partners
there are so many contemporary examples
that you end the book with and just want
to mention one more and then maybe open
it up to some conversation with the
audience and you know some more back and
forth but this I found to be actually an
extraordinary case case of Whitley Jones
an african-american woman in South
Carolina which is a stand-your-ground
state and she defended herself against
her boyfriend ended up in defense
stabbing it with a knife he died
actually the initially charges were not
going to be brought against her rate it
was actually it was felt that she in
fact had acted reasonably in the within
the doctrine of stand your ground and
then the state appealed that initial
decision not to charge correct yep but
what I found extraordinary was the
actually what the the the attorney for
the state said and why specifically a
charge had to be brought and I think
this actually ties together a lot of the
the things you've been telling us about
this evening
the solicitor for the state the
assistance listener said quote a woman's
right to stand her ground in a domestic
dispute is less than a man's right to
stand his ground with some stranger he's
gotten into a fight with exactly and
that is the nutshell of and this is also
this is an african-american woman so
she's there at the kind of the
intersection of racism and sexism and
even it much in you know doubly
disadvantaged in terms of how the law
would could possibly conceive for
legitimate use of self-defense
absolutely it's a case where I was drawn
to this case because I saw it as an
example of the law working the way it
was supposed to because it was obvious
there were witnesses she was she had
been abused by this man multiple times
she tried to escape she only killed him
when she couldn't get away and indeed at
the stand-your-ground hearing they
decided that it was reasonable for her
to have acted the way that she did and
then the state prosecutors came after
her with guns blazing and and and that
statement summarizes everything that
these laws were never intended to
protect women from domestic violence
within the man's castle that instead
these laws were designed against
stranger danger really and and part of
the part of the you know the goal of the
book is to illuminate the way in which
we participate and that sort of fear
generated discourse of steering stranger
danger that then provokes us to think
that we need to be individually
participating in armed citizenship
against all of these different
encroaching threats whether they're
criminal thugs or undocumented
immigrants or terrorists there's this
whole litany of threats that were
supposed to be afraid of and yet the
actual threats to women's safety are
often men they know and these laws were
not designed to protect them as far as I
know though whit Whitley Jones has
remained out you know free she's a free
woman as far as I can tell I don't think
that the prosecutors were were able to
get her into prison so perhaps one
example of the law working as and as it
maybe should i mean i think the issue of
stranger danger at this particular
moment is especially urgent because
there are so many different characters
who are being proposed as the strangers
that endanger us and i think it's a time
to sort of be very watchful of the
solicitation of fear and the ways in
which i'm you know people are being are
certain citizens are being deputized to
perhaps act in ways that are violent
towards other citizens that normally
yeah whether we're talking about the the
the border patrol or the policing of
public bathrooms which you know
essentially it's about policing borders
and invocations of protection that we
started with and coverture is an
invocation to a particularly racialized
gendered protection of white women and
and that's a recurring theme in American
history it justified the lynching of
more than 4,000 African Americans this
invocation of the the urgent need to
protect women and and I see recurrent
sort of echoes of that in our our fears
around bathrooms and the fear that
transgressive others are going to
threaten women and children's safety in
bathrooms so these are recurrent themes
and I hope that by excavating the
history we can be more mindful of them
when they crop up time after time let's
open it up to conversation and questions
with our audience here
[Music]
hi um I guess I'm just wondering hearing
all this like what can be done um not
just like what should be done from like
a law makers standpoint but like what
could we do yeah
did you have any ideas professor
Pellegrini I won one I mean I I don't
the book is not prescriptive I don't
really have at the end you know words of
wisdom in terms of what we need to do
aside from sort of greater awareness of
our past but one of the things I'm
starting to see is that anti-violence
work has to think constellation aliy it
has to be deliberate in seeing violence
not just as one thing so when I wrote
this as it isn't just about guns
although guns play you know a role in a
lot of these these stories these case
studies but to look at vectors of
violence as they're connected so
domestic violence like intimate partner
violence and the way in which that is
connected to mass incarceration and the
erosion of a social safety net and
violent policing and racial profiling
that these things are connected and that
we need to become really self-critical
about the way in which we engage in
certain kinds of practices that become
naturalized like this stranger danger
it becomes often very seductive to
imagine that you can protect yourself
from terrorists by packing your own
pistol although I don't really know how
that works but it's a seductive
narrative that you as an individual can
take your safety into your own hands and
so a lot of people they follow that
because it feels empowering but I think
we have to really actively push back
against that narrative and think more
collectively and constellation aliy
about the sources of violence
now I also think that some of this is
also what's the language we use to
describe actions in the world and so for
example whose actions to defend
themselves or their communities get
called violence whose get called justice
or defending freedom and I don't think
this is I think this is actually a
really deep question I don't know what
violence is I mean I think that what
gets named violence is its historical
it's like its context found and so we
need to sort of not assume that we all
know what violence is when we see it or
experience it and how to develop a
language and I think the history really
helps here because it gives us I think a
kind of complicated if er n't
complicated view of the present and
maybe it complicates it could slow down
our own reaction time potentially one of
the things that um Caroline was talking
about which came to my class today was
actually the talking about the Black
Panther Party and the and sort of it's
the crucial role it played in the
history of struggle for civil rights in
this country and the ways in which the
organization what has been characterized
in some histories of the period as
violent as non law-abiding when in fact
it was actually making use of the law in
deeply creative ways that were against
white supremacy and but if you have a
system organized around white supremacy
such that those of us that are white
don't even recognize it groups to stand
up for themselves to fight against it
might be experienced by those of us with
the privilege of our skin as somehow
acting violently against us one known
fact it's a it's actually acting in
accord with ideals of justice and
freedom right so how from whose percept
perspective do these stories even get
told right that's an excellent point
about the language that you use because
one thing I noticed is the way in which
the language of rioting gets used in
history incidences that are called race
riots actually end up being episodes in
which white supremacist violence
destroys entire black communities
and it's a it's a gesture that
obfuscates entire history so like the
Black Panther Party lives in sort of the
wider popular imagination as being
violent or anti white when in reality
their core principles were about social
justice and resistance to white
supremacist power and violence so yeah
so I need to be more careful about how
I'm using violence too but I think
absolutely we can all be more sort of
self reflexive as we think about sort of
our naturalized understandings of what
is violence versus what is justice and I
think that also I mean I love the way
that you use these early legal cases to
flesh out what's become a kind of
obvious Nisour for American you know
public life and I think it's also really
important not to think that law then
becomes determinative of every single
way we can think about things law
provides one language one set of
conceptual resources one you know tool
but it's not all of them so what other
languages do we get to use outside the
court of law I'm not a lawyer so I in
some sense I use a different language I
don't have to you know sort of cabin
what I'm saying in terms of what law
will recognize
hi do you see a connection between the
legal history of stand-your-ground laws
and the legal antecedents of say like
Trump's immigration policy is there a
connection between the domicile and an
extension of it to the homeland and kind
of the preservation of white masculinity
in that space yeah that's a great
question thank you so many levels yes
absolutely I don't even know where to
start I mean there's the there's the one
of the necessary factors in the
discourse of armed citizenship is is
about the creation of categories of
alienation and other nasarah akhmad
writes beautifully about the
conceptualization of the stranger other
so yes this this idea of the the
security threat to our borders that is
especially amplified in the wake of 9/11
and that talk about contributing to
naturalized knowledge and insecurities I
mean in the wake of 9/11 especially
right here you know in in New York City
we become fearful we become terrified
our borders have been breached so in a
lot of ways it becomes very convenience
to invoke these figures of alienation
and danger and use them as justification
for draconian and incredibly cruel
exclusionary laws yeah it's so many
different levels and yes these sort of
invocation of the homeland the the the
slippage between the sort of defensive
habitation and then this defense of the
entire homeland you can see it when you
look at Border Patrol to the deputize
ation of civilians armed white civilians
to go and patrol the border against
so-called illegal immigrants
again kind of serves that same kind of
constellation of exclusion that
concentrates power into particular kinds
of already propertied hands when I was
thinking both when when you were in my
class today but in sort of reading the
book I was thinking about and you will
know that you can tell me the exact
quote but this notion that you know a
good guy with a gun will always beat a
bad guy
yeah with a gun and so that one of these
you said is that the ability to identify
we know who the bad guys are that
actually produces the sense of ourselves
is the good guy
we need these bad objects out there that
define us and our goodness and I started
thinking about this in connection to
actually the brilliance and simplicity
of a president Trump's language during
his campaign about the bad hombres right
that's a which was extraordinary and for
many of us who are critical and aghast
at his policies and and also like the
simplicity of the speech and the
caricature that we don't understand our
works it actually works brilliantly to
just tag in this a broad way huge groups
of people and it's lack of specificity
is actually what makes it work yes it
attracts it it just you can magnetize
whomever you wish to put in there you
have to be scared of and then he sort of
you know correlates it to the border and
brown people it's really actually a
quite good use of language if you're if
they're you know trying to produce an us
them yeah Domitian to justify violence
yeah and the the kind of fuzziness of
those boundaries are deliberate that
almost anybody can fit into that
category I think that's that's a great
point and that's been a long-standing
tradition of sort of the armed
citizenship rhetoric is that those good
guys always know can always tell the
difference between the good guys and the
bad guys it's really entrenched in that
idea that if only there had been
somebody a good guy with a gun at the
pulse nightclub in Florida if only then
all those people would have been saved
and I think there's a kind of fit on a
fantasy level and you're the one who
does the psychoanalytic theory so you
can help to use this out a little bit
but I really believe there is on a
fantasy level people want to do good and
they want to be heroes
and so a lot of this discourse of armed
citizenship is about being that hero
becoming your own action hero where
you've got your gun you're in the right
place at the right time and you managed
to take out that bad guy and that that
comes up that's a recurrent theme the
good guys that are gonna find the bad
hombres and identify them and take them
out before they harm the innocent
citizens there is the you know if we
were gonna go with Melanie Klein I mean
this fantasy of the splitting right this
the purely good and the purely bad
because yeah actually it's it's very
hard to live and acknowledge all the
ways in which we fall short of our own
ideals and that we actually are
aggressive not only towards people we
don't know and who are strangers to us
and whose differences we might find
confusing but we actually have all sorts
of aggressive feelings towards people we
love how do we live with that well one
of the ways we live with it is sort of
in this unconscious way I think and ways
that also can be unfortunately
manipulated at a larger scale level as
we transfer all those negative feelings
that we actually find a bit unbearable
and destabilizing we transfer them onto
ready-made objects whom we've learned
are safe to hate and this is a I think
it's I do believe it's possible to live
more in the space of discomfort and not
have to act out but there is this way
the splitting of good into bad it has
catastrophic consequences it's not just
lived at the level of fantasy it has
lived some subjects bear the brunt of
being the bad objects so that others of
us can feel like we're good citizens so
that category of safety hate is just
growing proliferating right now oddly at
the other question
to what extent do you see this as a
uniquely American problem I mean when we
think about gun violence you know we I I
often associate that with you know the
greater availability of lethal weapons
and things like that but yeah you know
America isn't the only colonial or
imperial power yep so and this clearly
comes from English law so how is it
different in the United States versus
elsewhere yeah I think that's a great
point
um yes statistically in the United
States we have more guns than people and
that's unusual we have something like 5%
of the world's population in this
country but we have almost half of the
guns
so we're overachievers we're
overachieved we're totally overachievers
we're also overachievers in mass
shootings we have I mean astronomically
more mass shootings than any other pure
nation our mass shootings also another
unacknowledged fact about our mass
shootings is typically they are enacted
by angry white men and that somehow gets
lost amidst the the efforts to create
these bad these ready-made bad object
sets that are safe to hate but I don't
know I mean I think part of it is
corporate I think a part of it is a very
deliberate effort in the past couple of
decades by gun manufacturers to find new
ways to market the technology given a
waning interest in hunting used to be
several decades back hunting was the
number one reason for owning a firearm
and now people say they're number one
reason for owning a firearm is
self-defense so a lot of that perception
of urgent fear and anxiety is rooted in
you know a manufactured effort to create
a need for particular commodities
so but I don't know I mean this is this
is the sticky question is like why why
did this happen in the United States I
think it's a whole variety of different
interlocking sort of normalized ideas
about safety and also individualism
we're like really into our sovereign
subjectivity here too so it's like every
man for himself is really big in the
United States as well so I think it's
such an interesting question and but
what you just said about the I mean
there's a long tradition of the
glorification of the individual in the
United States a distrust of the federal
government and you put that together
with I think this not only the those are
the kind of targeting of so who's gonna
buy the weapons now - you know if as a
movement of way I mean there still are
large you know you know there's a lot of
hunting culture stole in the United
States but how do you you have to keep
you have to sell more and more weapons
so how do you target those new produce
cultivate this new market but I'm also
thinking about how neoliberalism fits
into this in the sense of as the the
government is in fact it's retreating
right from the provision of more and
more services for the public good so
people are being called upon as
individuals to do more than they were
historically and and you put that
alongside the ideology that already
distrusts government with a capital G
right so there's also a fantasy of
what's being distrusted and the sense of
the individual who pulls himself up by
his bootstraps I think you you have a
lot of trends that together would
produce an orientation towards gun
ownership and because you use the
language sites I think it's just a huge
hugely helpful
the DIY self-defense yeah and it is like
you said it is about self-care given the
shrinking of the welfare state and I
think these things are parallel I mean
that that explosion of do-it-yourself
security citizenship correlates with the
sort of late capitalist retreat from
social welfare so and and one of the
symptoms of this is increased
militarization so militarization of
police forces less investment
training for example or trying to
counteract implicit bias and more
investment in you know better weaponry
or more advanced weaponry militarization
also the citizenry deputies ation of the
quote Posse on the border so all of
these I think are symptoms of that kind
of neoliberal turned a self-care that is
beautifully compatible with that ethos
of arming yourself find more guns I mean
it goes back to this question what is to
be done I mean I think I think it's
people aren't hallucinating many people
in this country and not just here are in
fact more insecure economically for
example than they were even a decade ago
yeah so it's how does how is one called
to respond to that insecurity with what
resources and whose responsibility is it
to help with a shared insecurity if you
individualize that responsibility and
you also sell weapons at the same time I
think you've got a recipe for an awful
lot of violence yeah it's yeah
to pick up on the question about if this
is uniquely American you know I I'm
completely convinced by all you know all
that you have said generalizing but one
but I wonder if you thought about the
nature of the split in the United States
historically between urban and rural and
and is this really a product of a kind
of a kind of lion ization or
valorisation of of a kind of rural
America that it's existed since the time
of Thomas Jefferson so I'm thinking you
know do do so all these generalizations
work if we think about urban populations
which you know are not as heavily armed
who support gun rights who probably you
know most of the examples that you give
seem to me are really centered in a kind
of a rural population that maybe you
know still hunts but now increasingly
says no I need my guns for self-defense
and so just one of the cake cases that I
think I think about yeah